heiko maas bundesaußenminister warum ist
der kanzlerin ist jetzt der kragen
geplatzt frau war auch die kanzlerin
naiv also ich würde mal sagen dass ihr
der kragen geplatzt ist sondern wir sind
dabei auf das was wir sehen und
festgestellt haben eine angemessene
reaktion zu suchen wir sind ja keine
partei in diesem konflikt wir sind nur
der überbringer der schlechten nachricht
per navi ist in berlin behandelt worden
und zum glück geht es ihnen auch besser
und bei der behandlung haben wir
natürlich alle möglichkeiten gesucht um
die ärzte zu unterstützen und dabei auch
danach geforscht was kann er im körper
haben dabei haben wir diese feststellung
gemacht die wir öffentlich gemacht haben
die hinter ziemlich sicher ich bin
hundert prozent sicher das ist eine
untersuchung die von einem
außerordentlich qualifizierten labor
vorgenommen worden ist aber kennen auch
sagen wir haben gar keine absicht das
alleine nur bei uns zu lassen es ist ein
bilateraler konflikt zwischen
deutschland und russland und natürlich
haben wir alles erforderliche bereits in
die wege geleitet um die organisation
die internationale organisation die für
die überwachung des chemie waffen
übereinkommen das zuständig ist die
organisation für das verbot chemischer
waffen in die lage zu versetzen das zu
überprüfen die hat viele zertifizierte
labore die so etwas überprüfen können
dann muss man sich auch gar nicht auf
die deutschen laborergebnisse beruf und
dann wird die internationale
staatengemeinschaft denn es ist ein
verstoß gegen das chemie waffen abkommen
muss darauf reagieren wenn sich das
alles bestätigen sollte was wir im
moment gefunden haben und wovon wir
ausgehen noch mal die frage nach der
bundeskanzlerin war auch sie naiv haben
wir eine politik der naivität gegenüber
putin gemacht was soll denn die politik
der naivität sein also es gibt kaum ein
land bei dem die europäische union
bereits so viele sanktionen verhängt hat
also es gibt wirtschaftsfonds wurden je
nach der annexion der krim verhängt
worden sind es gibt listungen die
aufgrund von hacker-angriffen
durchgeführt worden sind wir haben
listungen in eine beantragt bei der
europäischen union ist und diplomaten
ausgewiesen worden
das kann man wirklich nicht sagen dass
man überhaupt nicht
also das wesen der diplomatie besteht
nicht sich nur noch mit denen zu treffen
mit denen man einer meinung ist dass wir
sind ja diplomatie besteht eher darin
sich mit denen zu treffen mit denen man
was zu klären hat und wir können
geografie auch nicht ändern russland ist
ein nachbar von uns in europa und
deshalb müssen wir im dialog bleiben
aber wenn solche dinge geschehen wie sie
jetzt geschehen sind die die verstöße
gegen internationales recht es sind dann
muss es nicht nur klar benannt werden
soll dann muss man auch eine angemessene
und eine effektive konsequenz daraus
ziehen und das wollen wir nicht alleine
weil es eben kein thema ist nur zwischen
deutschland und russland
das tun wir innerhalb der europäischen
union innerhalb der nato mit unseren g7
partnern und insofern ist das ein thema
für die ganze internationale gemeinde
haben schon erwähnt in der vali ist
aufgewacht die sicherheitsvorkehrungen
in der charité in berlin sind jetzt
verstärkt wurden die frage befürchten
sie denn tatsächlich auch hier in
deutschland dass man ihm nach dem leben
trachten könnten mehr zunächst wollen
wir dass ihm in deutschland nichts
geschieht und erna weine ist der opfer
das opfer eines mordanschlages also es
gibt anscheinend jemanden der ihn
umbringen wollte und das ist glaube ich
dann ganz logisch dass man wirklich
sicherheitsvorkehrungen trifft die
notwendig sind die angemessen sind das
ist ein fall der beschäftigt die ganze
welt öffentlichkeit und ich glaube
darauf hat herr navalny auch einen
anspruch einen anspruch und ein recht
marina weisband ist bei uns publizistin
sie sind in der ukraine geborene frau
weiß waren und jetzt bei bündnis 90 die
grünen wir haben schon zitiert angela
merkel fand markige worte sie sprach von
einem versuchten giftmord glauben sie
dass das putin jetzt beeindruckt hat er
angst
ich glaube dass man putin keine angst
machen kann solange man mit der linken
hand sanktionen verhängt und mit der
rechten hand eine starke wirtschaftliche
abhängigkeit aufbot
ich glaube dass wir unsere russland
politik zu stark auf der kooperation mit
der regierung immer wieder aufbauen
und immer wenn von russland
feindlichkeit gesprochen wird weil wir
putin kritisieren vergisst man das gros
land mehr ist als die aktuelle russische
regierung es gibt in russland sehr viele
ngo sehr viele demokratische akteure
viele parteien die deutsche
zivilgesellschaft und das
sitzen könnte über die wir eine gute
nachbarschaftliche beziehung bauen
könnten mit einer klaren absage an jede
zusammenarbeit mit einem diktatorischen
regime alexander rahr ist bei uns
osteuropa historiker sie beraten auch
das russische russische unternehmen
gazprom herra wir haben es in diesem ein
spielfilm auch aufgezählt attentate
gegen oppositionelle politiker der
tiergarten mord die cyber-attacken gegen
den bundestag des informationskampagnen
bei wahl ist in diesem deutsch
russischen verhältnis in dem berühmten
tatsächlich nicht immer die russische
seite der provokateur
das fragen sie mich also ich glaube das
ja eigentlich auf dem weg waren
trotzreaktion und trotzdem konflikte die
wir zwischen europa und russland haben
gerade zwischen deutschland und russland
das verhältnis wieder zu normalisieren
trotz sanktionen ich betone immer wieder
die russen sehen in den deutschen ihre
lieblings nation
man vergisst nicht dass russland sehr
viel dafür getan hat wenn die
wiedervereinigung deutschlands und
russland und vor allen dingen putin
glauben auch immer wieder und das zeigen
wir auch heutige gespräche die ich mit
dem russen führen dass man auf
deutschland setzt also das land das
praktisch durch deutsche anwalt in
europa werden kann
für den west aber jetzt sind die
beziehungen und vor allem bruch und
deshalb müssen beide seiten aus meiner
sicht genau nachdenken was wichtiger ist
in dieser weise moral wo der vernunft
ich konnte noch mal auf kind sehen
glauben sie denn ob sie sagen moral
aber ich sage auch wir müssen angesichts
dessen was ich davor gesagt aber was
aufgebaut worden es brücken aufzubauen
ist schwierig mit einem partner das eine
schließt das andere ja nicht aus moral
und das werden wir versuchen aber
gleichzeitig muss man auch sehen dass
brücken sehr schnell wieder abgebaut und
kaputt gemacht werden
und ich setze mich selbst persönlich
dafür ein dass es nicht passiert und ich
glaube dass hier
wir können über vieles reden aber herr
maas hat ja alles richtig gesagt aber
ich finde dass man trotzdem eine art von
zusammenarbeit mit russland in diesem
fall eher wirken müsste die eine seite
die deutsche sagt die russen liefern
nichts die russen sagen dasselbe über
deutschen
ich glaube warum warum können sich nicht
russische ärzte und deutsche ärzte
treffen und sich die analysen noch mal
anschauen immerhin haben deutsche und
russische ärzte zusammen in ordnung aber
das leben gerettet
vielleicht kann die ehefrau von na weil
ich auch bestimmen welche ärzte ihres
vertrauens aus russland kommen um ihren
mann noch einmal zu begutachten aber ich
finde die russische seite muss hier auch
noch gehört werden
sie hat das recht dazu um die weiteren
schritte zu machen und das untersuchung
in russland habe natürlich wie es zu
diesem motto schlag gekommen gekommen
ist wir begrüßen gregor gysi bei uns in
der runde der außenpolitische sprecher
der linken
herr gysi haben interessanterweise mit
spekulieren wollen sie haben im mdr
gesagt es könnte ja auch sein das ist
ein gegner dieser erdgasleitung nach
deutschland war oder ein beauftragter
gegner
wen meinen sie denn da meinen sie die
cia oder meinen sie das weiß ich nicht
das klassische absichtlich offen also
ich bin anwalt und deshalb bin ich immer
erst für aufklärung und dann für
verurteilung andere sind erst für
verurteilung oder nach aufklärung das
geht aber nicht
und ich finde eben dass er sehr viele
spekulationen gibt und ich hab nur
gesagt wenn man spekuliert kann man eben
auch eine gegenteilige spekulation
machen und sagen ein gegner der pipeline
hat sich gedacht wenn er das macht
unterstellen ja alle dass putin war und
dann wird die pipeline gefährdet sein
und sicher auch gefährdet und es gab
gleich forderung von lindner von göring
eckardt von merz von röttgen
die arbeiten an der pipeline
einzustellen ich wollte nur sagen
spekulationen haben keinen sinn
aufklärung jetzt sage ich also ich hier
meine spekulationen sofort zurück wenn
die anderen ihre auch zurückziehen um
aufklärung da kann man den druck erhöhen
bloß ich muss mal über den anfang
sprechen sie haben gesagt die
völkerrechtswidrige annexion der krippen
haben sie völlig recht aber vorher bei
der völkerrechtswidrigen krieg gegen
jugoslawien
vorher war die dem
sicherheitsratsbeschluss widersprechende
los trennung des kosovo
das heißt das völkerrecht mode nicht
mehr ernst genommen
es herrscht der zum recht der stärkeren
das sieht man auch bei der türkei die
machen alle was sie wollen natürlich
auch bei russland
das macht mehr in wirklichkeit an
denn wenn wir das völkerrecht nicht mehr
einhalten also weder der westen noch der
osten noch andere dann kommen wir eine
furchtbare situation und ich möchte auch
dass erst ausgliederung stadt will darf
ich mal fragen stellen vielleicht können
denn herr gysi vielleicht können wir
noch mal ordnen wir jetzt diese
historische debatte führen wird auf der
ganzen welt wissen ja hier die zeit hat
recherchiert dieser navalny wurde
natürlich rund um die uhr vom sfb fsb
beschattet natürlich ist es ein neues
eine neue variante von new york
es ist immer eine kombination von
giftstoffen das kann man nicht irgendwie
in der handtasche tragen dazu braucht es
labore
das muss also tatsächlich in der regie
eines überwachten systems geschehen sein
also passen sie auf folgende fragen wenn
die maschine nicht not gelandet wäre
wäre er tot sagt unsere ärzte enorm es
kam somit abgespritzt das hätte sie
nicht gemacht wenn sie nicht gift
gefunden hätten hinterher haben die
russischen ärzte gesagt er hatte kein
geld haben können wir sagen die ärzte
haben erst mal in unserem leben
dann hat putin durch vermittlung des
finnischen präsidenten zugestimmt dass
er nach deutschland kommt und hier
behandelt wird stellen sie sich mal vor
er hätte den mord angeordnet und dann
lässt er zu dass das hier aufgeklärt
wird das ist nicht besonders logisch ich
frage mich immer wer hat etwas davon
ich will ja nur fragen stellen es ist
auch nicht logisch dass man dasselbe
gibt darf man schon mal genommen hat
oder durch der verdacht gleich wieder
auf ihn
also ich weiß ja wie endlich nicht sehr
sehr wie die verschiedenen dienste
denken und deshalb sage ich ich möchte
eine aufklärung dazu müssen sie eine
chance haben
sie haben ein rechtshilfeersuchen
erstellt der außenminister hat gesagt
alles genehmigt worden aber die in
unserer justiz noch nicht übersandt
es wird nun eben zeit dass es auch
übersandt wird und dann das können wir
kontrollieren wir können kontrolliert ob
wirklich aufgeklärt wird oder wir fragen
gleich ein maß zwischendurch will ich
frau weiß band noch fragen welches
interesse frau weiß band sollte putin
denn haben um gregor gysi ist frage
aufzunehmen dass die suche nach dem
täter in seine richtung führt es ist ein
merkmal das sich durch russische morde
und einschüchterungsversuche durchzieht
das man nicht besonders verschleiert
dass man dahinter steckt um natürliche
oppositioneller abzusprechen
es wurde genauso wenn vor dem kreml
zufällig die überwachungskameras auswahl
natürlich ist das ein lautes jahre waren
ist und was wollt ihr jetzt tun
aber ganz ehrlich seine talkshow ist
kein rahmen in dem wir bestimmen werden
wer eine weile vergiftet hat seine
talkshow kann ein rahmen sein in der wir
über reaktionen und politik sprechen und
wenn wir für eine weile keine beweise
haben was ja völlig richtig ist dann
haben wir aber beweise für die annexion
der krim wir haben beweise für syrische
kriegsverbrechen wir haben beweise für
andere morde durch putin
wir haben beweise für die manipulation
durch putin für die
informationskampagnen wie viele beweise
brauchen wir um zu sehen jemand ist der
demokratie der westlichen gesellschaft
nicht wohlgesonnen vertritt eigene
interessen
und warum sollten wir uns abhängig
machen von so einer person das wäre die
politische frage die sich politische
frage merken wir uns nicht nur sondern
wir stellen sie auch herr maas trotzdem
nochmal zu der kritik aus moskau ihr
amtskollege lavrov sagt sie behindern
diesen aufklärungsprozess müsste genau
das geschehen was herr gysi gesagt haben
es müsste die möglichkeit geben dass man
an die informationen kommt die deutschen
haben die dieses bundeswehr institut hat
haben sie denn ihre westlichen partner
mit den informationen ausgestattet die
die russen nicht kriegen
es gibt eine organisation bei der
übrigen russland auch mitglied ist die
organisierte organisation für das verbot
chemischer waffen die vcw die auch im
salisbury fall also bei der vergiftung
gern hängt skript beauftragt worden ist
und die ist dafür zuständig und wir
haben diese organisationen in die lage
versetzt alle notwendigen untersuchungen
zu tätigen das ist auch der richtige ort
wir sind nicht der schiedsrichter wir
sind auch nicht der richter aber wir
selbst serien sind wir diejenigen die
hannawald aufgenommen haben und gott sei
dank haben die ärzte der charité es
geschafft ihn wieder gesund zu pflegen
und ich hoffe das ja auch wieder
vollständig gesund insofern gibt es eine
organisation eine internationale
organisation die dafür zuständig ist und
die wird die information bekommen die
dafür notwendig sind und dort ist dann
auch der richtige ort mit die aufklärung
und weil es mit 16 4 abkommen
wir haben eine russische botschafter
letzte woche freitag bei uns im
auswärtigen amt gewesen ist schon
präventiv im darauf hingewiesen dass wir
das ist das bundesministerium der justiz
und das ist das auswärtige amt alle
zustimmungen und genehmigungen dafür
erteilen wir dass ein
rechtshilfeersuchen positiv bescheidet
wird und das wird auch so sein das heißt
auch diese am besten das leben noch ja
dass das dauert aber es geht aber darum
ob wir irgend etwas zurückhalten oder
etwas nicht einen ewigen das hatte ich
ehrlich so wir haben selber ein
interesse daran dass aufgeklärt wird und
dafür gibt es eine organisation und
deren aufwand der sitzung dafür
begründet worden ist und er die kann das
auch in einer objektiven vorm tod im
übrigen auch mit russland natürlich kann
auch russland einen beitrag leisten
indem wenn die vcw die über mit die
ermittlungen übernehmen würde
zugang zu schaffen in russland zu dem
flugzeug zu den stellen auch die
ergebnisse die es bei den untersuchungen
im krankenhaus gegeben hat offen legen
also da kann jeder seinen beitrag
liefern wir haben ja überhaupt kein
interesse daran dass das bei uns liegen
bleibt weil wir eben in diesem konflikt
keine partei sind und ist kein
bilaterales thema alleine zwischen
auseinander und xterra und zu diesen
spekulationen noch mal wäre putin nicht
ein wahnsinnig schwacher präsident
werden oppositionelle mit einem chemie
kampfstoff umgebracht würden gegen
seinen expliziten weg das wollte ich
gerade sagen herr maas als diplomat als
chefdiplomat deutschlands wäre natürlich
die inszeniert jetzt mit beruf und mit
der russischen seite vor allen dingen
sagen wir nicht über navalny selbst zu
reden weil deutsche kriminalisten werden
nicht nach russland gelassen das glaube
ich nicht so eng sehen unsere beziehung
nicht und so viel vertrauen gibt es
nicht aber nutzen doch selbst das
interesse daran haben wenn navid schock
einwandfrei nachgewiesen wird hier in
berlin oder in münchen dass dort nach
geforscht wird wie dieses dieser
giftstoffe im körper von herrn reinecke
da kann es sein dass geheimdienst außer
kontrolle geraten sind ich
tippe eher darauf dass kriminelle
strukturen wir haben erlebt ja nicht
ungefährlich hat fielen viele
nachforschungen betrieben ich sehe auch
seine seine sendungen ja auch ständig
der hat sehr einflussreiche leute
außerhalb der politik attackiert sie
entblößt mit seinen drohungen mit seinen
filmen hier gemacht hat ich würde mich
nicht wundern wenn aus dieser ecke auch
was geben es ist natürlich auch alles
spekulation ich bin kann ich alles
machen was mein punkt ist ein anderer
meinung sie weniger dass man versuchen
will russland dazu zu überreden
vagabundierende chemiewaffen wenn es
solche gibt in russland ausfindig zu
machen wir dürfen nicht vergessen die
sowjetunion ist auseinandergefallen 1991
und dieses motto gab es hier nicht nur
in russischen föderation
auch das hier aber eines muss man
freunden dann schon mal sagen weil hier
werden ja wirklich spekulation in den
raum gesetzt die an absurdität nicht
mehr zu überbieten sind also dass die
gegner von nur zu den zwei giftanschlag
auf der man alle richtungen oder man
lässt das ganze geht darum welche
indizien gibt es ja und die indizien die
wir haben ist dass dieses gift das im
körper von hannawald nie gefunden wurde
und nicht nur in seinem körper sondern
auch an seinem körper ein gift ist aus
der nordgruppe es muss im übrigen nicht
das gleiche sein dass verwandt worden
ist in salisbury hannover als mit dem
argument so sagen wir das gleiche gibt
noch mal mit der unterschiedliche
geöffnet dazu wir wissen wie wir wissen
dass dieses gift in russland entwickelt
worden ist
russische forscher geben dazu
bereitwillig interviews
wir wissen aus dem spotlight dass er
russland zuzuordnen gewesen also es gibt
indizien dass ist schon mal der fall
gewesen ist das russische stellen mit
diesem gift gearbeitet haben und wenn
nun indizien für uns dazu kommen dass
russland erst mal darauf hinweist hätte
auf russischem boden oder im russische
luft morgen keine vergiftung gegeben das
gift hätte im jahr können in berlin
zugeführt worden seien machte er
betrachte ich das auch nicht als einen
beitrag zur aufklärung und wenn es
indizien gibt für uns das von davon da
wir wissen
dass das gift dort entwickelt worden ist
und auch schon einmal verwarnt worden
ist man sich nicht an der aufklärung
beteiligt ist das auch indiz dafür dass
man etwas zu verheimlichen
damals so dass er den schild das die
wahl haben oder auf deren grundlage wir
uns unsere meinung so habe der chef von
wirecard hat schon einmal gezeigt dass
er die formel hat der einer der erfinder
von naughty dog sitzt jetzt in den usa
es ist bekannt dass viele geheimdienste
das haben sicherlich auch der russische
hab ich gar keine zwei jahren passiert
dieses gift auch das muss man noch
einmal zur werbung sagt ihn wenn er das
war das höchste beweismittel nämlich den
man hier aus damit wir das alles gegen
ihn fest stellen also mehr für mich
gemacht verbrechen nicht nur renault
ging es hat ja dass meine erfahrungen
als anwalt das ist das rhetorische was
gewollt dass wir fragen welchen sinn
hätte es gibt eine alte rhetorische
kister stammt noch aus dem kgb handbuch
und das ist das was putin machen das ist
das was trump auch macht und beide
machen das hervorragend das heißt lügen
über das offensichtliche man nimmt etwas
ein russe wurde in einem russischen
flugzeugs aus russland nach russland
flog vergiftet mit einem russischen gift
das es nur in russland gibt mal das jahr
kommt massa mehrere geheimbund ist
falsch sagt stellt wilde spekulationen
in den raum und wir hier die wir jetzt
darüber reden könnten warum eigentlich
steht dieses verhältnis russland
deutschlands und eine kippe worum geht
es da in der tiefe sitzen und spielen
krimi-dinner und versuchen einander zu
beweisen wer wen wann wo vergiftet hat
und in welchen laboren wer sitzt das
bringt uns nicht weiter das ist nicht
der politische klar belegt den wir
brauchen um zu verstehen wie ist unsere
beziehung zu der regierung eines
manroland gut und wir können ihre frage
nun auch noch einmal aufgreifen und
sagen oppositionspolitiker und kritische
journalisten ergie sie leben in russland
natürlich extrem gefährlich wie macht
man das wäre eine ich bin auch da sehr
kritisch gegenüber den inneren zustand
und russland ich muss nur sagen
gorbatschow hat ein neues haus europa
vorgeschlagen das hat der westen
abgelehnt
putin hat 2000 moment butina 2001 im
bundestag gesprochen und hat die
zusammenarbeit auf allen gebieten
angeboten der westen war zu arrogant
jetzt hat er allerdings keine politik
sehr geändert und der stehe ich ja auch
kritisch gegenüber aber ich sage
noch einmal die verurteilung auch die
grünen fordern so top stop der public
library verstehen sie immer erst gleich
verurteilen ohne aufklärung und wir
möchten das erst aufgeklärt wird und
dass wir uns dann langsam also wenn die
über diese aktion mittel dann guckt sie
sich auch die vorstrafen anfänger können
wir uns darauf verständigen
und ich begrüße an der stelle die
journalistin jean an dem server ihr
vater boris neben soft wurde vor fünf
jahren in moskau erschossen sie ist uns
jetzt aus prag zugeschaltet wenn die
schalte klappt von dem server einen
guten abend
man hat täter überführt aber was haben
sie über die hintermänner erfahren
ich hab jetzt der diskussion aufmerksam
zugehört und habe den eindruck als ob
ich mich in einer show vor fünf jahren
befinden würde man hatte viele version
aufgestellt wer mein vater getötet hat
die ukrainischen dienste die
amerikanischen aber das ist alles nicht
eindeutig was die ermittlungen einen
betrifft ja die täter sind im gefängnis
aber die organisatoren oder auftraggeber
sind es heute nicht gefunden obwohl
beweise dafür vorliegen dass einer der
organisatoren ramzan kadyrov gewesen
sein könnte den man kennt man in
deutschland recht gut das ist der
präsident der republik tschetschenien
die zur russischen föderation gehört und
wir wissen nicht wer noch beteiligt
gewesen sein könnte aus der höchsten
politischen beamtenschaft da ich meine
mutter mein vater und das
untersuchungskomitee kann nach wie vor
kein motiv feststellen obwohl die ganze
welt meint dass es sich um eine politik
politisches motiv gehandelt haltung und
das untersuchungskomitee hat überhaupt
kein motiv benannt
so wird im russland von putin ermittelt
und es wird auch keine formale
ermittlungen in der causa navalny geben
das ist meine überzeugung noch glauben
sie sie kennen navalny gut sie sind mit
ihnen befreundet was glauben sie dass
alexej nawalny zugestoßen ist was ist
passiert
ich würde sagen dass eigentlich alles
schon gesagt wurde auch durch die
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel und durch
den bundesaußenminister war nie wurde
durch einen neuen job kampfstoff
vergiftet durch einen neuen kampfstoff
und es liegt wohl auf der hand dass eine
solche kampfstoff ein solches gift nicht
unter häuslichen bedingungen
synthetisiert werden kann dafür braucht
es speziallabor und was die vergiftung
war nicht an betrifft das ist das waren
die russischen dienste es war ein
mordanschlag main wollte ihn umbringen
aber gott sei dank das nicht mehr putin
im cockpit dieses flugzeug sondern
wunderbare piloten die das flugzeug
gelandet haben in homs und darum hat er
überlebt und die wunderbaren ärzte nicht
beamter aus dem gesundheitsministerium
sondern herzte die sofort begriffen
haben dass man alexei navalny vergiftet
hat sie haben das krankheitsbild gesehen
und sie haben sofort reagiert und ihm
atropin injiziert darum konnte er
überleben
und es ist ganz wichtig dass er nach
deutschland gekommen ist und putin die
russische regierung haben zwei tage lang
hindernisse gebautes wurde druck
aufgebaut
telefoniert es wurden mahnwachen gemacht
und so weiter und in irgendwelche
russischen fachleute werden ihm gesagt
haben in zwei tagen wird man diesen
kampfstoff nicht mehr nachweisen können
aber das bundeswehr labor war dazu in
der lage weil dort die modernste
ausrüstung vorhanden ist und man konnte
den typus dieses giftes feststellt und
das ist einfach nur gut in meinen augen
von dem server er braucht es ihrer
meinung nach für eine solche für ein
solches verbrechen einen befehl aus dem
kreml einen auftrag aus den kämmen oder
eine billigung
wenn man bedenkt dass alex ina weil
nehmen der bekannteste und
einflussreichste russische
oppositionspolitiker ist und der
wichtigste opponent von wladimir putin
würde ich sagen ohne billigung ohne
wissen um einen solchen anschlag wäre es
nicht möglich gewesen und nach dem was
mit alexei navalny passiert ist neige
ich immer mehr dazu dass wladimir putin
gewusst hat dass mein vater ermordet
werden sollte er laut und politische
morde udo mordanschläge die gibt es und
es wird immer druck ausgeübt auf alle
menschen auf journalisten auf
oppositionelle und dabei nie ist er
ständig angegriffen worden erst vor
einigen tagen in nowosibirsk oder in
anderen städten werden die koordinatoren
der stäbe von einer weil nie angegriffen
die werden von der polizei unter druck
gesetzt es werden verfahren eröffnet und
das ist ein ergebnis dessen dass
russland jetzt wieder ein klassisches
autoritäres regime herrscht von imz aber
was glauben sie was denken sie empfinden
die russen in bezug auf den fall navalny
warum ist
ist in russland so stellen
gibt es kein cdf in russland alle
fernsehkanäle stehen unter der kontrolle
des kreml und von putin und jetzt
versucht man natürlich das thema einfach
gut zureden irgendwelche vermutungen
aufzustellen die amerikaner oder
sonstwer um von der hauptsache
abzulenken
ich finde in russland verstehen sehr
viele was passiert das in menschen handy
vernünftig denken auch einflussreiche
menschen aber gleichzeitig gibt es
dieses gefühl der ohnmacht und das
sollte damit zu tun dass der druck so
schnell aufgebaut wird dass es schwer
ist zu reagieren
praktisch jeden monat werden bei uns
bekannte journalisten eingesperrt
es werden verfahren eröffnet
journalisten sind aus der opposition
werden permanent angegriffen und jetzt
ist genau das eingetreten worüber die
welt schon gesprochen hat und das
schafft eben eine atmosphäre der apathie
und gleichzeitig nimmt die angst
ernsthaft zu wie in jedem autokratischen
system die autokratie zieht die
daumenschrauben immer weiter hin und sie
alle hier in diesem tisch in berlin
wissen dass man in russland die
verfassung verhindert hat wladimir putin
kann unser land bis zum sankt
nimmerleinstag regieren und in der
presse wird der druck auch weiterhin
zunehmen
danke danke für dieses interview nach
prag und wir fragen hier in der runde
alexandra wie kann wie soll in ein
russlands ein parteien system entstehen
wie soll eine zivilgesellschaft
entstehen wie wir sie kennen
wenn menschen die dagegen opponieren
früher oder später im gefängnis landen
oder starten und das ist zu verurteilen
diese diese morde aber gleichzeitig ist
zu verurteilen das im anderen lager im
lager der unternehmer auch menschen
umgebracht werden übrigens gibt es nach
dem was ich weiß auch sehr viele tote
unter den abgeordneten der jet ski
partei das ist der schmerzhafte und
fürchterliche dramatische übergang
russlands aus 75 jahren totalitäre
herrschaft in etwas anderes ich hoffe in
einer demokratie aber das dauert viel
länger als würde als wir denken aber ich
will das nicht verharmlosen sie haben
recht die parteien existieren in
russland nur auf dem papier es gibt
übrigens bei den arbeiten keine eigene
partei hat sie an es gibt aber die
kommunisten die sind eigentlich
politisch gut und viel gefährlicher weil
sie auch gouverneure stellen es gibt
dennoch ski partei jetzt in der lage ist
eine riesige demonstration in hamburg zu
organisieren für ihren gouverneur den
putin abgesetzt hat das problem der
demokraten wie ich das sehe ist dass sie
sich nicht vereinigen können
jeder will dort chef sein und das ist
nicht nur in russland so das ist in
anderen ländern auch so wenn sie sich
alle vereinigen würden hinter ihr
verdienst hinter nach wahlen hinter
sonst jemandem
hinter dem soft damals dann hätten sie
denke ich
hätten sie eine kraft eine andere kraft
war weiß man interessante frage an sie
wenn er wolle nie wieder zurückkehren
kann in die politik wird er dann diese
kraft sein können wird er genau eine
solche rolle spielen können was ist
seine agenda
ich meine ich bin selber ich habe sehr
gemischte gefühle zu einer wollen die
selbst die spielen überhaupt keine rolle
bei dem giftanschlag der völlig
unabhängig davon ist
ich glaube das problem ist dass es in
russland kaum organisierte opposition
gibt und wie wir sehen wird der
opposition auch nicht erlaubt sich zu
organisieren und mussten konsumieren
medien an dass über 90 prozent des
medienkonsums laufen über das fernsehen
das komplett staatlich geprägt ist das
heißt es ist sehr sehr schwer so etwas
wie
eine opposition aufzubauen und ich
glaube wenn wir über freundschaftliche
beziehungen sprechen dann sollten wir
darüber sprechen projekte zu fördern in
denen die deutsche zivilgesellschaft mit
der russischen zivilgesellschaft
zusammen arbeitet und wenn es nicht
direkt ngo sind oder demokratische
projekte dann zumindest bildungsprojekte
damit kinder zusammen englisch lernen
können
es kann sehr sehr viel aus der
zivilgesellschaft heraus entstehen und
gefördert werden wenn man nicht um sein
leben fürchten muss und dass uns angst
haben ja und wir haben die sie vorhin
von alexander rahr gehört in welcher art
navalny arbeitet es gibt diese
dokumentationen die videos eben netz von
ihm die sind geklickt die sind natürlich
von den russen geschaut ergreift vor
allen dingen eine gierige elite an die
sind jetzt aber nicht irgendwie links
oder es sind mächtige menschen denen es
nur um ihren reichtum geht die sind
jetzt nicht links nein das weiß ich dass
das sehr unterschiedlich ich hab ja
schon mit vielen auch in der duma und
außerhalb gesprochen so links meinem
sinne würde die ganze drama machen
nein das ist was anderes ich werde ihm
was sagen ich habe meiner mandanten
deren mann ermordet worden ist in moskau
und der mörder angeblich nie gefunden
worden und ich vertrete sie nur dass sie
mich nicht falsch einschätzen aber das
war kein politischer mut das war einmal
zwischen reichen leuten sage ich mache
auch ganz interessant aber kann ich
nicht weiter darauf eingehen schon wegen
der anwaltlichen schweigepflicht
aber so viel kann ich sagen was ich mit
regulation meine ich sage dass es nicht
logisch ist dass putin wenn er wirklich
etwas damit zu tun hätte dann erlaubt
dass der patient nach deutschland kommt
nun gerettet wird da sagt sie auf wieder
spekulation aber wahrscheinlich haben
die experten zwei tage bevor ich etwas
falsches gesagt dass man das gar nicht
mehr nachweisen können verstehen sie wir
wir überlegen uns immer jeder nach
seiner jetzt auch auf leben und sagen
herr maas und fragen uns noch mal was
wir bisher eigentlich in moskau und in
russland erreicht haben den russen geht
es sicherlich im vergleich zu den 90er
oder nuller jahren wirtschaftlich besser
aber sie werden durch putin entmündigt
noch mal die frage nach unserer
russlandpolitik was hat sie bisher
eigentlich gebracht
wir müssen uns ganz einfach darüber klar
werden dass in großen internationalen
dossiers wir keine lösung oder ohne
russland erzielen wir sitzen mit
russland zusammen an einem tisch
zusammen mit den franzosen und
verhandeln über den frieden in der ost
ukraine
dort warten gibt es mittlerweile 10.000
tote die menschen in der ost ukraine
warten darauf dass das was in minsk war
vereinbart worden ist endlich umgesetzt
wir sitzen mit russland einem tisch in
der so genannten libyen konferenz auch
russland ein player ist im libyen
künstlich ist im sicherheitsrat der
vereinten nationen zusammen und
versuchen das nuklear abkommen mit dem
iran zu retten auch dort sitzen wir
unbedingt durch also man trifft wird
aber nicht einfach abgeschossen und
deshalb ist es auch notwendig und durch
das mit ihnen zu sprechen und den dialog
fortzusetzen aber das entbehrt uns ja
nicht bei solchen ereignissen ja auch
als internationale staatengemeinschaft
nicht nur zu reagieren sondern erst mal
tatsächlich aufzuklären und werden sie
die aufklärung zu ergebnissen führt bei
denen wir der auffassung sind dass wir
konsequenzen brauchen dann müssen diese
konsequenzen auch gezogen werden aber
genauso ist das richtig was frau
weisband sei nämlich dass wir das tun
wir oft dass wir unsere beziehungen zu
ländern identifizieren als beziehung zur
regierung
das gilt für andere länder auch und
deshalb versuchen werden das haben wir
in den letzten jahren noch einmal
intensiviert im hochschul- und
wissenschaftsbereich gemeinsame projekte
mit wissenschaftlern und forschern zu
machen wir sind dabei den
kulturschaffenden in russland enge
zusammenarbeit im herbst wird in
russland ein deutschlandjahr beginnen wo
wir versuchen wollen in die
zivilgesellschaft zu wirken
also es ist außer teilnahm deshalb ist
das ist außerordentlich wichtig aber es
entbehrt uns nicht dass wir in einem
solchen fall in eben gegen das
internationale chemiewaffen abkommen
verstoßen wird in dem jemand umgebracht
wird in dem es indizien gibt die
aufgeklärt werden müssen
ok uns dazu eine meinung bilden und
gegebenenfalls auch dazu reagieren
müssen ich muss auch hier schauen nicht
mehr sagen dass das in deutschland bl
ein strategisches interesse an guten
beziehungen zu russland und china wir
sind nicht in derselben situation wie
die usa
wir haben eine andere geschichte das
darf man alles dabei nicht vergessen vor
allen dingen ist die frage welche
produktive rolle russland dann spielt
und was man eigentlich bewirkt in der
art und weise indem wir mit ihnen
zusammenarbeiten aber wir müssen und
wollen an diesem abend noch nach belarus
schauen
der geht lukaschenka hart gegen
oppositionelle vor
und in russland wurde navalny vergiftet
das ist für manche kein zufall
sie gehen weiter auf die straße
jetzt erst recht die belarussische
demokratiebewegung fordert die
freilassung ihrer gallionsfigur maria
kohl s nikkor was it den minsk in
untersuchungshaft
vor allem aber fordern sie den rücktritt
des autokraten lukaschenko ein mann von
putins gnaden der seinen besitzer
ausdrücklich warnt russland sollte
wachsam bleiben
dort können auch politische ereignisse
stattfinden vielleicht ganz ohne grund
und wissen sie welche schlussfolgerungen
die russische führung und dichter
ausgezogen haben wenn der ausfällt dann
fällt als nächstes russland noch hält
putin fest an lukaschenko und manche
sehen einen zusammenhang zwischen
belarus und dem anschlag auf rabbani der
russische oppositionspolitiker dimitri
gut kopf vermutet es könnte ein
einschüchterungsversuch gewesen sein
die russische führung hat gesehen was in
belarus passiert ist und sie bereiten
sich vor
deswegen glaube ich dass der
giftanschlag auf navalny teil eines
plans ist
vor weisband die vergiftung als warnung
an die karossen und an die russin ist
das in ihren augen plausibel
ja wir haben gesehen als der ukraine
konflikt ausgebrochen ist dass putin
sehr stark ich darf mich so ausdrücken
aber das dass er angst bekommen hat und
das ja auch noch mal härter gegen
oppositionelle im eigenen land
durchgegriffen ist weil in russland
erste demonstrationen gestartet sind und
die sehr gewaltsam wieder geprügelt
wurden es hat einen ansteckungseffekt
diese demonstrationen
ich will mich wirklich wirklich nicht
wie herr gysi richtig sagte in
spekulationen vertiefen war es das oder
war es dass er wenig putin wäre würde
ich einfach fallen lassen und jemand
anderes einsetzen
aber ich glaube dass in der eau rouge
gerade zeigt wie nichts anderes den
hauptkonflikt unserer zeit es ist nicht
dass merkel zwischen russland und den
usa steht denn der kalte krieg ist
vorbei
ich glaube dass der aktuelle konflikt
nicht mehr das wirtschaftssystem ist
sondern das staatssystem das
regierungssystem und da geht es um
autokratie versus demokratie da stehen
die aktuelle russische regierung die
aktuelle bilder russische regierung und
die aktuelle us regierung auf einer
seite und wir sollen der seite des
feldes auf einer seite des feldes das
sind alles regierungen die autokratisch
neigen und wir europa deutschland was
auch immer sie nehmen sollten diejenigen
sein die auf der anderen seite stehen
wir können so viel mehr sein als ein
bauernopfer in diesem spiel russland
oder usa
wir können das fanal sein das sagt wir
sind für demokratie für menschenrecht
gut jetzt